[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'expertise
comme tous les soirs sur Public Sénat 90
minutes et deux grands thèmes
l'actualité pour commencer et un
président de la République optimiste sur
le conflit des raffineries hier soir sur
France 2 il prévoyait un retour à la
normale la semaine prochaine on va
décortiquer son intervention sur le fond
et la forme analyser aussi la stratégie
la CGT qui veut faire mentir Emmanuel
Macron et appelle à étendre le mouvement
à la SNCF et à la RATP mardi prochain en
attendant c'est toujours aussi galère de
faire son plein d'essence et puis notre
second débat vous le savez on choisit
volontairement décaler de l'actualité du
jour je vous propose de revenir sur une
idée du chef de l'État lancé le 15
septembre dernier mieux répartir les
réfugiés et demandeurs d'asile sur tout
le territoire le projet provoque un
tollé à droite comme chez ce sénateur LR
du Cantal
il semble que pour certaines nous soyons
destinés qu'à accueillir les migrants
pour soulager les banlieues vous
l'avouez presque et les éoliennes pour
éclairer les urbains la ruralité
sous-thérite sous territoire de la
France c'est non des centres d'accueil
des réfugiés existent déjà en zone
rurales comment fonctionnent-ils peut-on
les multiplier sans provoquer le rejet
des habitants réponses de nos experts
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
donc l'actu et l'actu ce soir c'est
encore le conflit dans les raffineries
totales qui lâchent du lest mais la CGT
en veut plus Sandra cerca
le mouvement de blocage des raffineries
continuent malgré le geste de Total qui
propose 6% d'augmentation de salaire
pour 2023 et une prime exceptionnelle
correspondant à un mois de salaire pas
suffisant et pas la bonne méthode pour
les syndicats qui continuent d'appeler à
la grève pour les grévistes ce bonus ne
doit pas se substituer à une hausse des
salaires sur 2022 il réclame 10% de
hausse pour faire face à l'inflation la
CGT et FO demande des négociations
immédiates avec la direction il devrait
être reçu ce soir à 20h c'est un
dialogue social une ouverture de
négociation ça fait deux semaines que ça
dure total énergie a pris la température
des organisations hier mais aucune
proposition n'a été faite officiellement
au syndicat la seule réponse qu'ils ont
apporté c'est transmettre une liste de
personnels aux autorités pour les
réquisitionner sur le site alors que les
à la pompe ne désemplissent pas Emmanuel
Macron lançait hier soir sur le plateau
de France 2 un appel à la responsabilité
que la CGT permettent au pays de
fonctionner et que dans une entreprise
ou un accord majoritaire et signé elle
le respecte je suis pour le dialogue
social je suis pour le respect de tous
nos droits constitutionnels la grève a
été levée dans l'un des sites Esso exon
mobile info sur mer mais pas à Total
énergie le ministre de l'Économie Bruno
Le Maire réaffirme que la priorité de
trouver un accord salarial évidemment
que total doit augmenter ses salaires la
commencer à le faire cette entreprise a
aujourd'hui des bénéfices qui sont
importants total à verser des dividendes
il faut que le partage de la valeur en
France soit équitable au total a les
moyens d'augmenter les salaires à les
moyens d'augmenter l'intéressement et la
participation pour assurer les
expéditions de carburant les salariés du
de Marie près de Dunkerque ont été
réquisitionnés cet après-midi leurs
collègues d'exon mobile en
Seine-Maritime ont eux aussi déjà fait
l'objet hier d'une réquisition au total
5 des 7 raffineries françaises sont
encore affectés par le mouvement de
grève la CGT RATP appelle quant à elle à
une journée de grève et de mobilisation
en Île-de-France mardi 18 octobre
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce débat Sophie Coignières
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
au Point et auteur de la tyrannie de la
médiocrité libre qui vient de paraître
aux éditions de l'Observatoire Pablo Pio
Vivien bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue regardez
avec Michaud bonsoir bienvenue directeur
général adjoint de l'Institut de sondage
Opinionway et Laetitia cruppa guitariste
à mes côtés comme chaque jeudi et chaque
mardi je reviens sur la déclaration de
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir je commence
avec vous Sophie cogna quand il dit
grosso modo ça va s'améliorer la semaine
prochaine je disais en titre il est
optimiste il prend quand même un petit
risque oui c'est un risque politique je
suis bien d'accord avec vous puisque
enfin sauf s'il dispose d'éléments ou
divinatoires ou objectif qui qui nous
échappent rien ne rien ne lui permettait
hier soir et rien ne nous permet ce soir
de de conjecturer sur la sortie de crise
ça date et ces modalités donc on voit
bien que au stade où nous en sommes et
bien le président de la République a
fait ce qu'on appelle un voeux pieux
réquisition il y a des premiers camions
de livraison qui sont sortis du site
près de Dunkerque ici de mardi que non
dont on parlait à l'instant de reportage
il y a des négociations formelles de
vraies négociations
de ce que j'ai pu enquêter on voit bien
que les réquisitions mettent quand même
beaucoup de temps enfin je veux dire
entre le moment où le préfet signe
l'arrêtait et le moment où dans votre
pompe à essence vous que soyez où que
vous soyez en France vous avez de
nouveau du carburant il va se passer
éventuellement du temps à supposer que
les acquisitions se multiplica
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez le le
l'acquisitions qui ont été prises donc
sur pour l'instant à ce site ne sont pas
de nature à débloquer la totalité de la
situation il y a un deuxième site je
croyais le cités le premier site total
à partir de 14h aujourd'hui
un point sur les réquisitions il faut
faire très attention parce que il y a
une jurisprudence en 2010 lors de
réformes qui avaient été souhaité par
Nicolas Sarkozy il y avait eu des grèves
dans les dans les raffineries et à ce
moment-là les préfets certains préfets
avaient pris des arrêtés pour faire
travailler les ouvriers contre leur gré
entre guillemets en cassant le droit de
grève et le Conseil d'État avait dit non
vous n'avez pas le droit vous n'avez pas
le droit de prendre les arrêtés que vous
avez pris parce que vous faites
travailler trop de gens c'est à dire
qu'il faut que ça soit le strict minimum
d'autres arrêtés repris dans la foulée
exactement et du coup mais du coup ce
que je voulais dire c'est que on ne
retrouvera pas un rythme normal
nécessairement ce sera forcément le
strict minimum cette émission hier soir
elle était consacrée aux questions
internationales et bon on l'a bien vu le
président a dû parler de de ce contexte
des raffineries de l'actualité vous
l'avez senti comment à l'aise dans
l'exercice un peu en pétrir dans cette
crise Pablo comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure par Sophie Goignard c'est-à-dire
que il a essayé de faire une prophétie
autorisatrice je suis pas certain en
fait qu'elle aille jusqu'au bout toutes
les façons au départ c'est Caroline Roux
qui a un peu pris les devants et qui a
décidé en fait de parler de cette
question à la base c'était pas ça qui
avait été négocié lui ce qu'il voulait
c'était juste faire figure d'homme le le
président un peu au-dessus de la mêlée
qui ne parle que des sujets
internationaux et tout d'un coup on l'a
on l'a ramené une autre émission dans
deux semaines dans deux semaines il faut
quand même exactement il s'avère que le
sujet brûlant auquel beaucoup de
Français à attendre des réponses je
pense qu'il avait dû donner son accord
pour que la question soit posée on peut
imaginer
on est tout à fait d'accord mais ça ça
se mais ça se discute en amont et
l'Elysée était tout à fait et en plus
ils savaient intérêt à en parler
évidemment qui ne pouvait pas éviter
cette question en pleine crise de
pénurie de carburant c'est impossible de
parler pendant une heure que l'Ukraine
et ça éclipse un peu le reste c'est à
dire que ce qu'on retient de son
intervention d'hier finalement c'est
cette déclaration optimise sur le sur le
le conflit dans la finir un peu moins le
positionnement de la France sur Poutine
l'Ukraine etc etc je voudrais qu'on
parle de l'opinion avec vous
avec Michao parce que il y a eu ce
dernier sondage qu'on a récupéré là en
cette fin d'après-midi de de jeudi
sondage réalisé par
doxabagone consulting pour Le Figaro sur
les réquisitions approuvez-vous la
décision du gouvernement de
réquisitionner les salariés en grève et
la question était précise des dépôts des
sauts exon mobile le oui est assez
massif quand même on a un OUI à 65% hier
Cédric il y avait un sondage qui nous
donnait une opinion publique française
partagée 42% approuvé la grève 40% les
approuvés est-ce que tu es difficile de
répondre mais est-ce que l'opinion est
petit à petit en train de basculer bon
alors ça c'est les jours qui viennent
qui nous le diront et sur ces questions
là effectivement l'opinion est parfois
un peu ambivalente on peut comprendre
que les Français ressentent une forme
d'empathie par rapport à une lutte
sociale dans un contexte inflationniste
tendu dans un contexte économique qui
est pas qui est pas très simple donc il
peut y avoir une forme de sympathie
spontanée pour qu'ils ont des mouvements
sociaux et puis simultanément il y a
aussi des blocages et les conséquences
des blocages qui sont vécues au
quotidien qui ont des conséquences très
tangibles sur la vie des français ce qui
crée cette peut-être cette ambivalence
et cette opinion qui a du mal à se
positionner pour l'instant ça veut dire
qu'on voudrait bien obtenir les 6%
d'augmentation de salaire que que les
salariés de Total obtenus
comment dirais-je
soit la désinvolture soit l'optimisme
démesuré du gouvernement par la voix de
son porte-parole Olivier Véran notamment
qui a fait preuve disons de maladresse
en disant qu'il n'y avait pas de pénurie
c'est quand même enfin c'est une faute
politique évidente pour un porte-parole
du gouvernement et bien effectivement ça
a permis à la CGT de comment dirais-je
d'installer le mouvement face à bon un
employeur qui était pas spécialement on
va dire écoutant
et à pouvoir politique qui était on va
dire indifférent donc comptez chez à ce
moment-là est-ce que à l'inverse c'est
la courte échelle est pas en train de de
s'inverser le gouvernement je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit c'est à
peu tôt je pense pour pour vraiment le
mesurer ou pas mais il est vrai que le
gouvernement s'est repositionné je
trouve que les propos de Bruno Le Maire
vous avez diffusé était très très
intéressant ce matin parce que quand on
suit au long cours la manière de
s'exprimer le vocabulaire employé par
Bruno Le Maire on voit bien que ce matin
il s'était quand même gauchisé de
manière assez importante avec enfin ce
discours sur le partage de la valeur qui
a discours qui me paraît d'ailleurs tout
à fait légitime avec la question
centrale dans notre société aujourd'hui
et donc la Bruno Le Maire a essayé en
effet de de parler aux Français au plus
grand nombre sur cette idée des
inégalités du pouvoir d'achat après je
dois dire une semaine ou c'était pas
vraiment le cas donc en effet
aujourd'hui la CGT permet au
gouvernement je dirais de se
repositionner mais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'ils font de ces marges
toutes les entreprises il y a des PME
qui sont un peu dans alors vous avez
tout à fait raison avec une grosse
différence entre les petites entreprises
et les plus grosses là en l'occurrence
quand on parle de Total énergie et
d'exon mobile on est plutôt plus grosse
et elle elles font des très grosses
marges aujourd'hui c'est marge ou est-ce
qu'elles vont elles vont dans la poche
des actionnaires principalement avec des
augmentations substantielles aussi pour
le pour le PDG et cette question en fait
des salaires qui en fait depuis
maintenant plusieurs dizaines d'années
ronge vraiment le quotidien des Français
fonde une partie de nos inégalités parce
que vous avez des Français vous avez une
courbe en gros des salaires qui ne suit
pas la courbe de l'inflation et les
Français le voient et les Français
perdent en pouvoir d'achat tout tous les
ans et donc au bout d'un moment il y a
une crispation non mais allez-y vas-y
non non les Français n'ont pas perdu
chaque année du pouvoir d'achat si on
regarde enfin moi je me fie à l'INSEE on
se met d'accord sur sur la source on
voit bien que il y a il y a eu notamment
pendant le le quinquennat qui vient de
s'achever il y a eu une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat en moyenne alors après
effectivement
exactement en fait pour les plus faibles
revenus pour les plus faibles revenus il
y a pour être très très faible revenu il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation pour l'achat
or là effectivement il y a une il y a
une colère en fait qui commence un peu à
généraliser et ce qui va se passer mardi
avec en fait vous avez d'autres secteurs
d'activité qui vont qui vont qui vont
rejoindre la grève vous avez parlé de la
SNCF et de la RATP il y a aussi les
routiers qui ont annoncé
du Parisien Aujourd'hui en France qui
sortent là en cette fin d'après-midi une
note des renseignements alors on appelle
plus à les renseignements généraux mais
je vais dire les RG parce que tout le
monde comprend qui effectivement évoque
une crainte de contagion les dockers le
secteur automobile voilà d'autres
secteurs on a appris hier qui avait un
mouvement de grève qui démarrait chez
EDF dans enfin en tout cas dans
certaines centrales nucléaires donc il y
a ça cette stratégie là elle existe mais
bien sûr parce que en fait c'est Bruno
Le Maire l'a dit il y a une stratégie de
la part de la CGT et des syndicats qui
rejoint en fait une dynamique sociale
qui est aujourd'hui est une est une
dynamique qui porte sur la question de
du partage de la valeur et de la de la
de la valeur générée par le travail et
aujourd'hui tant qu'on n'aura pas de
solution à apporter aux travailleurs et
aux travailleurs sur cette question là
évidemment ils seront en colère ils en
ont globalement les travailleurs en ont
marre de voir que le fruit de leur
labeur tout ce qu'il mette en fait dans
leur 35 heures dans 37 heures ou dans
leur 40 heures de travail hebdomadaire
part dans les poches d'actionnaires qui
parfois sont même pas français la Pablo
ce que vous dites le mot colère c'est
vraiment sur sur cette colère que vont
capitaliser les politiques parce que
entre ce soir et mardi il y a dimanche
et dimanche c'est la grande
manifestation qui de la nuance voilà de
la France insoumise surtout avec majon
contre la vie chère et qu'est-ce qu'on
va chercher chez les Français c'est la
colère des Français parce que vous avez
vu que habilement a fuité le salaire
moyen alors après il a été discuté fact
checker etc de des personnes qui
travaillent dans ces raffineries de 5000
euros alors il faut être précis c'est
salaire plus simple participation plus
intéressante d'accord mais quand même il
faudrait se mettre d'accord sur le
baromètre déjà qu'on utilise vous savez
une fois François Hollande avait dit
au-delà de telle somme on est riche
parce que je crois qu'on a pas tous la
même définition finalement de la
richesse et de ce avec quoi on peut
vivre ce qui est intéressant avec Michao
c'est que ça intervient dans un contexte
où la l'opinion française est quand même
ballotté peut-être
fatigué
une perte de confiance est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça aujourd'hui cette rentrée
absolument le climat d'opinion en cette
rentrée est extrêmement morose à des
niveaux d'optimisme qui sont très bas
31% des français seulement qui sont
optimistes pour l'avenir de la France
17% pour l'avenir du monde vous voyez un
pessimisme qui la majoritaire et parce
qu'il y a une conjonction une
accumulation de crise effectivement la
crise inflationniste qu'on voit
actuellement elle alimente toute une
série de revendications sociales dans
les entreprises
d'abord parce que l'inflation c'est un
phénomène qui est vu comme massif touche
toutes les catégories de la population
et pas seulement les plus pauvres qui
sont évidemment les plus exposés au
risque inflationnistes mais les
catégories quand un petit peu plus de
revenus les seniors catégories
socioprofessionnelles dites supérieures
elles aussi ressentent les effets de
l'inflation donc ça touche toutes les
catégories et c'est vu comme un
phénomène durable c'est un phénomène qui
va rester qui va pas s'arrêter demain
donc ça ça crée énormément d'inquiétudes
et puis tout ça c'est la toile de fond
générale des inquiétudes des inquiétudes
les crises mondiales qu'on voit
actuellement les tensions géopolitiques
l'inquiétude environnementales bref tout
ça se conjugue pour créer un climat qui
est extrêmement
absolument noir extrêmement inquiétant
alors c'est aussi pour ça que le pré
dans la République évidemment a voulu
prendre la parole une première fois hier
soir une seconde dans deux semaines sur
France 2 On va regarder l'audience de la
voilà de l'intervention du président de
la République on va dire les correcte en
tête devant TF1 avec près de 5 millions
400000 téléspectateurs alors
là on a un peu mélangé des chiffres je
crois mais bon parce qu'il y a le JT
aussi de TF1 qui est resté haut et le
good doctor je suis pas sûr que ce soit
le prime enfin bon c'est pas très grave
ce qui est sûr c'est que sur toute la
première partie de l'intervention du
chef de l'État France 2 et devant TF1
c'est pas un chiffre d'audience non plus
complètement dingue il est assez
classique des audiences du du JT à cette
heure là bon ça s'appelait l'événement
Laetitia et on peut dire que c'en était
un parce que c'était la première fois
que Emmanuel Macron a accepté une
invitation du service public est-ce que
ça marque un changement dans sa
communication oui c'est la première fois
pas qu'il dit oui au service public
pendant la campagne présidentielle
rappelez-vous Thomas il a été le seul
absent de la grande émission Elisée 2022
et ils avaient été obligé de diffuser un
extrait de son meeting pour le l'égalité
de parole vous imaginez l'embarras donc
oui du côté de france télé ça grinçait
des dents d'autant que en juin il avait
accepté de donner une interview mais à
c'est à vous qui est produit par une
boîte de prod extérieur donc la
rédaction de France Télévisions était un
peu énervé donc oui c'est une nouvelle
méthode de communication pour Emmanuel
Macron d'autant que vous l'avez dit il y
aura un deuxième round le 26 octobre
pourquoi deux interviews aussi
rapprochés parce que son entourage et
puis certainement lui aussi a remarqué
que finalement en ce moment c'était flou
que personne n'avait encore compris
vraiment le cap du second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron qui cédait beaucoup
déplacé aussi sur la scène
internationale il a délaissé un peu la
politique intérieure et du coup c'est
conseillé on dit bon ces deux interviews
ça
de d'Emmanuel Macron alors il a eu une
adresse aux français c'était le 22 juin
juste après les élections législatives
très mitigées pour lui bon il appelait
les oppositions à se positionner et puis
il avait trouvé une nouvelle méthode la
méthode Coué
j'ai confiance dans l'esprit de
responsabilité de tous j'ai surtout
confiance en vous en nous vous avez en
avril et en juin fait deux choix clairs
et j'en prends acte ma responsabilité
c'est de les faire vivre
et de les faire vivre à votre service
pour que la France soit plus forte et
que les réponses soient plus adaptées
construites différemment mais plus
adaptés au défi de votre quotidien et du
pays on ne cesse de répéter en politique
il y a les mots et les actes alors
peut-être que son nouveau spin doctor
son nouveau conseiller en communication
Frédéric Michel va aider Emmanuel Macron
a passé à l'action Frédéric Michel il
vient du groupe média de repère Murdoch
new Scorp et donc c'est un nouveau venu
à l'Élysée peut-être même qu'il a joué
un peu son rôle et qu'il a soufflé à
l'oreille du président d'accepter
l'invitation enfin du service public
alors l'objectif de ces deux émissions
on comprend bien c'est de montrer qu'il
y a un président élisé qui et qui va
nous donner un cap écouter la réaction
de Guillaume gonta le président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat
encore de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on fait
enfin je veux dire on est sur une crise
climatique une crise sociale une crise
énergétique crise diplomatique aussi
enfin sur la question sur la question
ukrainienne quels sont nos perspectives
si ce n'est de savoir ce qu'on va faire
demain et de voilà enfin on a on a
besoin d'avoir un peu de consistance de
savoir où on va et je dirais que c'est
pas l'intervention du président de la
République hier qui nous a rassuré
propos d'un opposant mais Sophie Cognard
on peut quand même si on analyse les
missions d'hier soir être je sais pas
c'est peut-être que vous serez pas
d'accord mais un peu d'accord alors
c'est peut-être l'émission du 26 qui va
lui permettre de donner un cap enfin on
est on sera six mois quasiment à présent
d'élection alors élection c'est vrai que
hier soir a priori enfin jusqu'à ce que
l'actualité rattrape le conducteur
initial de l'émission il ne devait être
question que de politique internationale
donc c'est à la fois un sujet sur le sur
lequel l'opinion a des attentes fortes
surtout et puis le début de la guerre en
Ukraine et en même temps ça n'est pas
sur ce n'est pas là où sont les sujets
les plus urticants je veux parler
notamment du pouvoir d'achat
éventuellement de l'angoisse climatique
etc donc bon premier point donc du coup
légère indulgence du jury bon maintenant
il est vrai que
ni enfin sur le sujet initial que la
politique étrangère ni sur le sujet
immédiat et brûlant qui est celui donc
des pénuries il n'a montré il a il a
tenté de faire de la pédagogie alors au
passage évidemment ils avaient des
petits problèmes de de projection des
des graphiques qui ajoutaient comment
dirais-je un petit élément léger et
presque ironique dans le dans le
scénario mais il a essayé de jouer cette
carte qui est de mon point de vue le
domaine où il est le meilleur veut dire
je vais vous expliquer pour faire quoi
mais
la demande aujourd'hui n'est pas
simplement je vais vous expliquer c'est
à dire que le président super brillant
qui dit d'accord ok j'ai compris votre
problème alors maintenant voilà je vous
expliquais comment on va faire il me
semble aujourd'hui
insuffisant en termes de communication
et je pense pour rebondir sur ce qu'a
dit Laetitia que d'ailleurs il y a un
rapport entre ceci et cela c'est-à-dire
que ce retard à l'allumage en termes de
comment dirais-je de deuxième
quinquennat et bien il est notamment lié
au fait que les les ressorts de
communication de séduction etc que le
président avait pendant le premier
quinquennat fonctionne moins bien et
fonctionne d'autant moins bien que cette
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien le le
contrat à jouer une partition différente
et et en fait le centre de gravité
pouvoir il s'est un tout petit peu quand
même décalé vers le Parlement
qui qui changerait de bicyclette et qui
serait un peu en déséquilibre et je
trouve que c'est un petit peu ce qu'on a
ressenti hier soir parce que finalement
dire qu'il faut continuer à parler à
Poutine et puis faire un petit
commentaire sur ce que serait la
dissuasion nucléaire
ça
a provoqué un certain nombre de comment
dirais-je de nouvelles polémiques alors
après tout on en parle mais ça n'a pas
été de nature
à éclairer le téléspectateur c'est ce
que vous avez retenu aussi le côté
pédagogue du président de la République
pédago ressort effectivement très
fortement moi j'ai pensé tout de suite
en voyant ces différents graphiques ces
cartes c'est exactement la même
communication que celle qui adoptait
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing dans les années
70 qui était la dernière grande période
d'inflation lui aussi venait à la
télévision alors les deux étaient
ministres de l'économie d'ailleurs pour
montrer des graphiques etc donc là il y
a quelque chose qui est une vraie
innovation au plan de la communication
etc ce n'était pas le président de la
République dans une dans une émission de
de grande écoute et puis le deuxième
élément c'est sur le fond je trouvais
que la posture était quand même très
traditionnelle d'abord l'international
le domaine réservé du chef de l'État
chef des armées si une volonté de
reprendre de la hauteur de se
représentialiser puisque là il est aussi
démonétisé par le fait que justement
elle ne pourra pas se représenter à
l'issue du du quinquennat deuxième
élément au-delà des des questions
internationales ou sur lesquels
effectivement il a une connaissance
technique qui est assez poussée par sa
fonction cette volonté de protéger les
Français
bâtir la paix rassurer ça aussi c'est
très présidentiel enfin là il y avait
des accents chirakiens 2003 qui était
qui était quand même assez assez
frappant donc voilà sur la forme
effectivement cette volonté de
vulgariser les grands enjeux
et puis sur le fond une posture très
présidentielle si on se projette sur la
prochaine le prochain rendez-vous donc
26 octobre je reviens à cette question
de peut-être que c'est là qu'il y aura
un cap un peu plus clair Pablo piovivien
il y a quand même cette volonté affichée
par Emmanuel Macron d'être un président
en réformateur et c'est plus compliqué
peut-être de réformer un pays fatigué
inquiet que vous nous décriviez déjà
archipelisé on l'a maintain de fois
analysé sur ce sur ce plateau ça marche
de manoeuvre de réformateur elle se
réduit est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée oui je suis je suis
assez d'accord après il faut s'entendre
sur ce que ça veut dire être un
réformateur et quelle réforme porter moi
je pense que c'est pas forcément celle
que vous attendez mais c'est un
réformateur
sans à part cette question de la de la
réforme des retraites par exemple
paramétrique des retraites je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas de cape et
d'ailleurs ça a été théorisé je trouve
dans un livre qui vient de sortir qui
parle le directeur de cabinet de
Elisabeth borne Aurélien Rousseau qui
était auparavant le patron de l'ARS
d'Île-de-France qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'épreuve et le rebond et dans
ce livre en fait Aurélien Rousseau
explique en prenant l'exemple de la de
la crise du covid ou lui il était à
l'ARS que l'État stratège c'est fini que
en gros on doit l'État doit répondre
doit être fluide doit être mouvant et en
fonction des crises auxquelles il va
être confronté en gros réagir de façon
différenciée à chaque fois mais donc
mais vraiment c'est je vous jure faut le
lire pour le croire il dit non mais ça
ne sert ça sert à rien en fait de faire
des plans sur la comète ça sert à rien
en fait de se projeter dans X années
puisque on va être confronté à des
crises comme ça perpétuelles et et
systématique et en fait finalement de
plus en plus resserré il parle lui je
pense qu'il a en tête des crises
sanitaires mais en fait on pourrait
aussi parler des crises sociales et là
ce qui s'est passé avec avec la grève
dans les raffineries bah c'est un peu ça
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ils n'ont pas vu
en fait il pilote à vue ils se disent
genre oh le jour le jour tiens on va
faire ça tiens on va faire ça et le côté
pédago que Emmanuel Macron a en fait il
est pédagogique quoi sur l'explication
sur le constat il dit bon bah voilà il y
a ça voici les forces en présence et
cetera mais à la fin des fins qu'est-ce
qu'il fait comme proposition en fait
pour sortir à part dire la semaine
prochaine nous il y aura plus de
problème dans les raffineries j'espère
que il y a pas de proposition oui mais
c'est pas lui non mais c'était quand
même une émission sur la sur le la
France à l'international nous pouvions
pas quand même quelle proposition il
fait dire bâtir la paix bâtir la pêche
je suis désolé mais c'est un mot qui qui
ne le dit il continue de dire par
exemple il faut dialoguer avec piscine
alors que certains lui reproche donc ça
est-ce que c'est un cap ou pas mais
c'est quand même une voilà une une
volonté a fait affirmière mais il fut un
temps où lorsqu'on réfléchissait aux
questions euh
géostratégiques et aux questions
internationales vous aviez des
oppositions très fortes à entre la
gauche et la droite et même au sein de
la gauche et au sein de la droite avec
des visions du monde mais qui était
autrement plus pêchu que juste dire on
va bâtir la paix et puis j'ai passé un
coup de téléphone à Vladimir et ensuite
sur Emmanuel Macron à l'international
parce que je ne sais pas ce que vous
vous avez dans vos enquêtes d'opinion
mais il me semble que quand même la
question de l'arme nucléaire brandi par
Poutine sous-entendu et dans toutes les
têtes des Français et cette troisième
guerre mondiale et cette apocalypse
nucléaire aussi Joe Biden
tout ça aussi dans l'esprit des Français
et hier moi je trouve qu'il était très
clair quand il a dit si la Russie
utilise l'arme tactique nucléaire sur
l'Ukraine nous ne riposterons pas et bah
ça c'est quand même la formation pour
moi qui était principale dans cette
interview c'est-à-dire que nous n'en
verrons pas l'arme nucléaire et donc on
rentrera pas dans une guerre mondiale il
a dit nous ne sommes pas en guerre nous
soutenons uniquement l'Ukraine c'est
tout ça c'est très important on peut
considérer que c'est un cas parce que
vous êtes sur cette ligne Sophie Cognard
oui enfin
moi je trouve que enfin sincèrement pour
moi le passage sur nucléaire a pas été
son meilleur passage en tant que en tant
que président d'une nation qui a l'arme
nucléaire je crois bon et s'il était
trop allusif d'une certaine et non parce
qu'il a été trop précis parce que parce
qu'il faut parce que la dissuasion
nucléaire enfin je veux dire ne joue on
en parle mieux c'est c'était ça la
doctrine
c'est pour ça que je comprends pas
pourquoi avant de il a dit qu'il fallait
pas surtout pas en parler avant d'en
parler donc il y a une légère petite
contradiction peut-être en revanche moi
je serais moins sévère sur
c'est enfin je vais dire
son discours concernant la politique
étrangère parce que c'est vrai que
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de lieux communs je suis d'accord avec
vous qui ont été prononcé mais il y a
quand même deux ou trois deux ou trois
choses sur lesquelles je les trouvais
clair très précis en fin de en fin
d'interview par exemple
sur laserbaïdjan il a été assez ferme
c'est à dire en expliquant qu'on n'avait
pas de contreagasi avec l'Azerbaïdjan
quand aucun cas on ne transigerait pour
quelques pour quelques mètres cubes de
gaz sur le soutien à apporter à
l'Arménie etc alors effectivement
ensuite on peut si on avait le temps
d'épiloguer sur ça on pourrait aussi
dire que OUI à l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies son attitude à l'égard du
président iranien et peut-être un peu
ambigu etc mais je trouve qu'il a été
assez clair dans sa ligne sur en gros on
a les valeurs que nous portons que ce
soit dans notre attitude sur la guerre
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine que ce soit
sur l'Iran que ce soit sur l'Azerbaïdjan
et l'Arménie les valeurs que nous
portons ne sont pas négociables alors
ensuite effectivement ça n'est pas
l'annonce d'un grand plan d'action mais
c'est quelque chose dont il est
comptable c'est-à-dire que ensuite on
revient au contexte social demain matin
si demain matin il prend il prend une
position une décision qui contrevient à
cela ça lui sera quand même opposable
donc dire qu'il a dit simplement je veux
la paix non mais c'est pas faux mais
c'est impossible en fait ce qui m'ennuie
plus profondément c'est que il n'a
jamais donné de véritable cadres à son
action au niveau international
c'est-à-dire dire oui il faut négocier
avec Vladimir Poutine dont acte mais qui
négocie quand dans quel cadre est-ce que
c'est je sais pas au niveau de l'Union
européenne et dans ces cas-là est-ce
qu'il faut peut-être revoir les règles
aujourd'hui dont se prennent les
décisions au sein de l'Union européenne
sur la question de ces frontières
orientales lorsqu'il parle de
l'Azerbaïdjan c'est super en fait qui
disent que la France on a pu rate contre
un gaziers etc mais donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ne parle pas moi c'est ça que
j'attends d'un président de la
République de la France j'attends qu'il
me dise ok quel est le cadre en fait
international que l'on peut proposer à
l'ensemble du monde qui puisse prendre à
bras le corps ce type de problème comme
en Azerbaïdjan et pas juste faire des
relations bilatérales où je vais appeler
Vladimir Poutine et je vais lui dire
calme-toi on a entendu vos arguments à
la l'autre jour je reviens à ce à ce
contexte de évidemment de tension
sociale de grève dans les raffineries de
menaces d'extension du conflit à
d'autres secteurs d'activités
est-ce que vous avez pu évaluer à quel
courant politique ça profitait parce
qu'on parle de de la nuque on a vu
Mathilde panot pour aller fille qui
était sur l'une des raffineries hier il
y a des grévistes de
Total qui vont aller à la journée contre
la vie chère dimanche alors que la CGT
nationalement ni participent pas est-ce
qu'on peut évaluer ça est-ce que ça
profite à la nuque et ça lui permet de
sortir d'une phase de de crise interne
qui a été qui a été quand même longue ou
peut-être au rassemblement national
qu'on entend beaucoup moins d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous pouvez l'analyser alors
là aussi désolé
mais c'est sans doute un peu trop tôt
parce qu'il faut voir justement les
effets se diffusent dans l'opinion
notamment de ce qui va se passer ce
week-end et on voit bien les les
différentes tentatives en tout cas qui
s'organisent pour essayer de profiter de
de tout cela ce qui est certain c'est
cette question des pénuries c'est
quelque chose qui est très fondamental
dans l'opinion publique et ce n'est pas
uniquement la pénuries de carburant
c'est les pénuries d'électricité les
pénuries de gaz et pénurie énergétiques
d'une manière générale renvoie à un
imaginaire qu'on avait déjà vu
d'ailleurs au moment de la crise du
covid avec la pénurie de masse de
respirateur etc qui est celui d'un
affaiblissement des structures de l'État
et l'État en France c'est quand même
l'épine Lépine dorsale la colonne
vertébrale de la de la nation on a le
sentiment que
les choses peuvent se déliter c'est vrai
en matière sanitaire on l'a vu c'est
vrai là en ce moment avec une inquiétude
sur le modèle social et la question des
des retraites c'est vrai maintenant sur
des questions énergétique c'est vrai
aussi en matière d'éducation bref on a
ce sentiment diffus d'un affaiblissement
peut-être d'un effondrement prochain de
ce qui structurait la société française
et donc au-delà de la question des
pénuries qui se jouent au jour le jour
et des difficultés très concrètes
qu'elle provoque dans le quotidien des
Français et il y a quelque chose de plus
profond qui renforce cette inquiétude
générale et donc ça ça pose aussi la
question de la réforme des retraites on
l'a évoqué rapidement on va terminer ce
débat autour de ce thème et je propose à
Audrey betas de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir Audrey bienvenue puisque
le Elisabeth borne recevait aujourd'hui
les chefs des groupes parlementaires
autour de cette question de la réforme
des retraites oui on entre dans la
fameuse phase de concertation qu'elle
avait annoncé il y a 15 jours même si
vous en doutez les échanges ont beaucoup
porté sur l'actualité et sur les
blocages Bruno Retailleau a même parlé
de prise d'otage de la part la des
syndicats mais bon on va se concentrer
sur la réforme des retraites depuis fin
septembre quelques lignes ont bougé on
s'en doutait déjà mais les chefs des
groupes ont eu la confirmation la
réforme des retraites ne se fera pas par
amendement du projet de loi finance de
la sécurité sociale souvenez-vous même
François Bayrou l'Allier d'Emmanuel
Macron était bon vent debout contre
cette idée elle est donc mise de côté
selon ses félicités Guillaume Gontard le
chef de fil du groupe écologiste au
Sénat qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
c'était un gain par rapport à il a 15
jours pour le reste il est très critique
écoutez-le au micro de Marion Delpech on
est totalement en désaccord avec leur
orientation qui est qui est proposée
et voilà cet âge de 65 ans toute façon
et pour nous une une rouge quoi on peut
voir aussi qu'on a un gouvernement
vraiment qui avance à qui avant sa vue
et pourquoi justement cette retraite et
cette précipitation sur sur les
retraites c'est vrai qu'on peut vraiment
se poser cette question pourquoi
c'est-à-dire quand on voit toutes les
les analyses qui peuvent être faits il
n'y a pas d'urgence on a et puis en plus
dans la période actuelle dans la tension
actuelle pourquoi c'est parce que en
fait ce gouvernement n'a grande majorité
essaye d'en chercher une n'est pas
claire sur ses orientations et notamment
ben là pour le coup c'est un appel aux
républicains et c'est d'essayer de
trouver une majorité avec avec les
républicains donc voilà comment on
avance aujourd'hui dans notre pays alors
qu'on a de véritables urgences face à
nous alors justement Audrey comment les
autres chefs de délégation parlementaire
on réagit alors les républicains je vais
y venir mais avant je voudrais qu'on
écoute Hervé Marseille c'est le patron
du groupe centriste au Sénat il pourrait
être un allié dans cette réforme parce
qu'il trouve que la réunion avec la
première ministre c'est plutôt bien
passé que tout le monde a joué carte sur
table et il pense même qu'un compromis
pourrait voir le jour avant la fin de
l'année il optimiste pour cela il a une
idée toute faite pour Elisabeth borne
écoutez
déjà chaque année un texte comme
celui-là il serait simple que le
gouvernement reprenne celui du Sénat ça
éviterait d'ailleurs de perdre beaucoup
de temps parce que ça ressemble de très
près à la recherche d'une solution
quand au Républicain Bruno Retailleau et
Olivier Marley ont conseillé au
gouvernement de mieux défendre sa
réforme et d'expliquer aux Français
qu'elle n'est pas faite contre eux mais
pour le pouvoir d'achat des plus anciens
et puis les journalistes n'ont pas pu
s'empêcher de leur poser la fameuse
question sur la volonté d'Edouard
Philippe le patron d'horizon membre de
la majorité de repousser l'âge de la
retraite à 67 ans écoutez leur réponse
un peu à ça
cultivent comment se fait-il qu'il était
incapable de faire la moindre réforme
des retraites à l'époque une réforme où
on ne parlait pas aussi peu du report de
l'âge légal et que aujourd'hui on se
réveillant il découvre que il faut aller
jusqu'à 67 ans
parce que les Français sont descendus
dans la rue aucun courage politique à
l'époque donc aujourd'hui le plus mal
placé pour pour jouer les des 20 ans
guerre vous l'avez vu on peut dire que
les choses commencent assez
difficilement pour trouver une majorité
avec les républicains merci Audrey
Sophie Coignières est-ce que une réforme
des retraites dans quoi quatre mois au
début de l'année 2023 ça vous semble
réaliste dans ce contexte à la fois
politique on parlait de la fragilité
évidemment l'absence de majorité absolue
contexte social qu'on a décrit largement
et puis sociétale cette société
française inquiète et pessimiste
pour le moins compliqué pour le moins
compliqué il me semble que effectivement
enfin ce qui a été dit sur le fait que
effectivement il y a un jeu politique
pour essayer de rallier les LR c'est à
dire de les mettre face à leur
contradiction c'est une variable qui
existe mais il y en a une autre dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure qui à mon avis
est tout à fait déterminante et mais
finalement qui comment dirais-je qui va
peut-être conduire à de grosses
déconvenues pour un gouvernement qui
risque quand même très gros et président
qui risque très gros avec ses dents
c'est que
si Emmanuel Macron veut continuer de
porter le costume de réformateur il est
obligé de faire la réforme des retraites
c'est pas que ça l'amuse mais il est
obligé ce sera le marqueur de son second
quinquennat d'une certaine façon en 2017
souvenez-vous petit flashback rapide il
y avait deux piliers à la transformation
révolutionnaire que nous vendait
Emmanuel Macron c'était la réforme des
retraites d'ailleurs pas du tout
celle-ci c'était la réforme
avec un système universel et puis vous
aviez la réforme de l'État
la réforme de l'État elle a fait psy
très très vite c'est-à-dire que une fois
que le statut de la SNCF etc a été
réformée en gros tout le monde a
commencé par Édouard Philippe et dit bon
c'est passé maintenant on va quand même
pas se coltiner toute la réforme de
l'État le rapport qui avait été commandé
pour le fameux cap 2022 vous savez on
devait avoir vraiment une grande réforme
de l'État qui devait aboutir à une
baisse du nombre de fonctionnaires mais
pas du tout parce qu'on allait couper
des têtes et faire comment le comité de
la hache mais parce que les changements
de structure allaient forcément
engendrer des économies via tout ça est
passé par perte et profit le rapport a
été classé verticalement donc il reste
quoi il restait les retraites et puis
les retraites bon j'ai pas besoin de
vous vous souvenez parfaitement du
scénario et donc aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron pendant la campagne pour des
raisons notamment électorales a été
chercher l'électorat de droite avec la
fixation d'un âge de départ légal à 65
il ne peut plus reculer une nouvelle
fois enfin c'est encore une fois c'est
un faux suspense qui doit dur depuis
plus de 5 ans donc en fait il est face à
une sorte de enfin des injonctions
contradictoires d'une part effectivement
c'est une réforme très risquée mais
d'autres parts c'est une c'est
l'ingrédient indispensable pour
continuer à être un président et
formateur
en termes de cohérence avec Pablo Pio
Vivien un risque pour l'instant les il y
a pas d'unité syndicale dans les
conflits dont on parle c'est la CGT qui
est quand même même si est faux à
rejoindre la CGT chez Total énergie
c'est quand même la CGT qui est en
première ligne en revanche sur les
retraites il y a une forme d'unité
syndicale d'une animiste pour dire on
veut pas d'un report de Las Vegas bien
sûr il risque de se passer exactement ce
qui s'est passé lorsqu'il a voulu faire
passer la réforme des retraites la
première fois c'est à dire qu'il y
aurait énormément de gens dans la rue
après il faut savoir qu'est-ce que ça
fait à un gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron
d'avoir des gens dans la rue la fois
dernière il y a eu quelques bougies ils
ont pris on va dire j'avais un ministre
qui avait parlé on prend le temps de la
démocratie bon donc ça veut dire qu'ils
avaient au début ils voulaient faire ça
en quelques semaines puis après ça a été
quelques mois et puis finalement ils ont
rallongé tant et si bien qu'il est
arrivé le covid et que là du coup ça a
dû ça a dû voilà être mis sous le
capteur d'abandonné ça a été abandonné
là ils vont la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'ils vont s'y prendre c'est à
dire que est-ce que ça va être Manu
militariste c'est-à-dire bon il y a un
million de gens dans la rue bon bah tant
pis on la passe quand même ce qui est
tout à fait possible moi je pense que la
stratégie aujourd'hui d'Emmanuel Macron
et de la majorité elle est finalement un
peu la même que celle de la France
insoumise c'est à dire c'est cette
conflictualiser c'est-à-dire de tout
latéraliser c'est à dire que le conflit
ne les ne leur fait pas peur
ils veulent casser en fait les l'unité
en fait du peuple français pour
capitaliser sur ce qu'ils imaginent
pouvoir être une majorité ou ce qu'on
appelle un bloc un dernier mot avec
Michaud vous nous avez parlé de
lassitude et de pessimiste ça peut
basculer en colère
parce qu'il y a eu ce pari d'une France
tellement fatiguée que finalement il n'y
aurait pas massivement dans la rue vous
voyez ce que je veux dire oui absolument
tout est tout est possible ce qui est
très frappant dans le contexte actuel
c'est que justement
il peut y avoir des transformations
extrêmement rapides de l'environnement
politique et par exemple le
replaçons-nous un an en arrière en
novembre personne ne pensait à la crise
en Ukraine en novembre de l'année
dernière il n'y avait pas d'inflation en
France on était presque en avec des prix
qui baissaient donc vous voyez à quel
point le contexte est capable de se
transformer dans un sens ou dans un
autre de manière extrêmement rapide et
très soudaine et ça effectivement c'est
un paramètre supplémentaire qui est très
difficile à mesurer même impossible mais
que doit tenter de prendre en compte le
gouvernement pour conduire des réformes
aussi structurelles et puis le deuxième
élément on a déjà dit la démonétisation
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que sa fenêtre
d'opportunités politiques elle se réduit
de plus en plus parce que l'échéance des
élections européennes et 2024 donc la
dernière avant cette échéance la
dernière séquence
utile pour véritablement faire des
réformes et entrer dans ce quinquennat
c'est 2023 merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat
Sophie cognage rappelle évidemment le
titre de votre livre la tyrannie de la
médiocrité c'est pour être un bon thème
de débat sur ce plateau qui sait il
vient de sortir aux éditions de
l'Observatoire merci encore